The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN GUTTAG: So
today, we're going
to move on to a fairly
different world than the world
we've been living in.
And this will be a
world we'll be living in
for quite a few lectures.
But before I do that,
I want to get back
to just finish up something
that Professor Grimson started.
You may recall he talked
about family trees
and raised the question,
was it actually
possible to represent all
ancestral relationships
as a tree?
Well, as a counterexample,
I'm sure some of you
are familiar with Oedipus Rex.
For those of you
who are not, I'm
happy give you a plot summary
at the end of the lecture.
It's a rather bizarre plot.
But it was captured in a
wonderful song by Tom Lehrer.
The short story is Oedipus
ended up marrying his mother
and having four children.
And Tom Lehrer, if you've
never heard of Tom Lehrer,
you're missing one of the
world's funniest songwriters.
And he had a wonderful
song called "Oedipus Rex,"
and I recommend this YouTube as
a way to go and listen to it.
And you can gather from the
quote what the story is about.
I also recommend the
play, by the way.
It's really kind of
appalling what goes on,
but it's beautiful.
Back to the main topic,
here's the relevant reading--
a small bit from later in
the book and then chapter 14.
You may notice that
we're not actually going
through the book in order.
And the reason we're not
doing that is because we're
trying to get you
information you need in time
to do problem sets.
So the topic of today is
really uncertainty and the fact
that the world is really
annoyingly hard to understand.
This is a signpost
related to 6.0002,
but we won't go into too
much detail about it.
We'd rather things were certain.
But in fact, they
usually are not.
And this is a place
where 6.0002 diverges
from the typical
introductory computer science
course, which focuses on
things that are functional--
given an input, you always
get the same output.
It's predictable.
And we like to do that,
because that's easier to teach.
But in fact, for reasons
we'll be talking about,
it's not nearly as
useful if you're
trying to actually
write computations that
help you understand the world.
You have to face
uncertainty head on.
An analogy is for many
years people, believed
in Newtonian mechanics--
I guess they still
do in 8.01 maybe--
that every effect has a cause.
An apple falls from the
tree because of gravity,
and you know where
it's going to land.
And the world can be
understood causally.
And people believed this
really for quite a long time,
most of history,
until the early part
of the 20th century, when
the so-called Copenhagen
doctrine was put forth.
The doctrine there from
Bohr and Heisenberg,
two very famous
physicists, was one
of what they called
causal nondeterminism.
And their assertion was that
the world at its very most
fundamental level behaves in
a way that you cannot predict.
It's OK to make a statement that
x is highly likely to occur,
almost certain to occur,
but for no case can
you make a statement
x will occur.
Nothing has a
probability of one.
This was hard for us to
imagine today, when we all
know quantum mechanics.
But at the turn of the century,
this was a shocking statement.
And two other very
well-known physicists,
Albert Einstein and
Schrodinger, basically
said, no, this is wrong.
Bohr, Heisenberg,
you guys are idiots.
It's just not true.
They probably didn't
call them idiots.
And this is most exemplified
by Einstein's famous quote
that "God does not play dice,"
which is indicative of the fact
that this was actually a
discussion that permeated
not just the world of physics,
but society in general people
really turned it into
literally a religious issue,
as did Einstein.
Well, so now we should
ask the question,
does it really matter?
And to illustrate
that, I need two coins.
I forgot to bring
any coins with me.
Does anyone got a
coin they can lend me?
AUDIENCE: I have some coins.
JOHN GUTTAG: All right.
Now, this is where I see how
much the students trust me.
Do I get a penny?
Do I get a silver dollar?
So what do we got here?
This is someone who's entrusting
me with quarters, not so bad.
So we'll take these quarters,
and we'll shake them up,
and we'll put them
down on the table.
And now, we'll ask a question--
do we have two heads, two
tails, or one head and one tail?
So who thinks we have two heads?
Who thinks we have two tails?
Who thinks we have one of each?
Well, clearly, everyone except
a few people-- for example,
the Indians fan, who clearly
believe in the counterfactual--
made the most
probabilistic decision.
But in fact, there is
no nondeterminism here.
I know the answer.
And so in some sense,
it doesn't matter
whether it's deterministic,
because in fact, it's
not causally nondeterministic.
The answer is quite clear,
but you don't know the answer.
And so whether or not the world
is inherently unpredictable,
the fact that we never have
complete knowledge of the world
suggests that we
might as well treat
it as inherently unpredictable.
And so this is called
predictive nondeterminism.
And this really is
what's going to underline
pretty much everything else
we're going to be doing here.
No comments about that?
I wouldn't do that to you.
Thank you.
I know you are wishing to
get interest on the money,
but you don't get any.
AUDIENCE: Was it heads or tails?
JOHN GUTTAG: What was that?
So when we think about
nondeterminism in computation,
we use the word
stochastic process.
And that's any
process that's ongoing
in which the next state depends
upon the previous states
in some random element.
So typically up till now
when we've written code,
one line of code
did depended only
on what the previous
lines of code did.
There was no randomness.
Here, we're going
to have randomness.
And we can see the
difference if we
look at these two
specifications of rolling a die.
The first one, returns
an int between 1 and 6,
is what I'll call
underdetermined.
By that I mean you can't tell
what it's going to return.
Maybe it will return a different
number each time you call it,
but it's not required to.
Maybe it will return three
every time you call it.
The second specification
requires randomness.
It says, it returns are
randomly chosen int.
So it requires a
stochastic implementation.
Let's look at how we implement
a random process in Python.
We start by importing
the library random.
This is not to
say you can import
any random library you want.
It's to say you import
the library called random.
Let me get my pen out of here.
And we'll use that a lot.
And then we're going to use
the function in random called
random.choice.
It takes as an argument a
sequence, in this case a list,
and randomly chooses
one member of the list.
And it chooses it uniformly.
It's a uniform distribution.
And what that means is
that it's equally probable
that it will choose any
number in that list each time
you call it.
We'll later look
at distributions
that are not uniform,
not equally probable,
where things are weighted.
But here, it's quite
simple, it's just uniform.
And then we can test
it using testRoll--
take some number of n and
rolls the die that many times
and creates a string
telling us what we got.
So let's consider running this
on, say, testRoll of five.
And we'll ask the
question, if we run it,
how probable is it that it's
going to return a string
of five 1's?
How do we do that?
Now, how many people
here are either in 6.041
or would have taken 6.041?
Raise your hand.
Oh, good.
So very few of you
know probability.
That helps.
So how do we think
about that question?
Well, probability, to me at
least, is all about counting,
especially discrete
probability, which
is what we're looking at here.
What you do is you start by
counting the number of events
that have the
property of interest
and the number of
possible events
and divide one by the other.
So if we think about
rolling a die five times,
we can enumerate all of
the possible outcomes
of five rolls.
So if we look at that,
what are the outcomes?
Well, I could get five 1's.
I could get four 1's and a 2
or four 1's and 3, skip a few.
The next one would be three 1's,
a 2 and a 1, then a 2 and 2,
and finally, at
the end, all 6's.
So remember, we
looked before at when
we're looking at optimization
problems about binary numbers.
And we said we can look at all
the possible choices of items
in the knapsack by a
vector of 0's and 1's.
We said, how many possible
choices are there?
Well, it depended on how
many binary numbers you could
get in that number of digits.
Well, here we're doing the same
thing, but instead of base 2,
it's base 6.
And so the number of possible
outcomes of five rolls
is quite high.
How many of those are five 1's?
Only one of them, right?
So in order to get the
probability of a five 1's, I
divide 1 by 6 to the fifth.
Does that makes
sense to everybody?
So in fact, we see
it's highly unlikely.
The probability of a
five 1's is quite small.
Now, suppose we were to
ask about the probability
of something else--
instead of five 1's, say 53421.
It kind of looks more likely
than that than five 1's
in a row, but of
course, it isn't, right?
Any specific combination
is equally probable.
And there are a lot of them.
So this is all the probability
we're going to think about we
could think about this way, as
simply a matter of counting--
the number of possible events,
the number of events that have
the property of interest--
in this case being all 1's--
and then simple division.
Given that framework, there
were three basic facts
about probability we're
going to be using a lot of.
So one, probabilities
always range from 0 to 1.
How do we know that?
Well, we've got a
fraction, right?
And the denominator is
all possible events.
The numerator is the subset
of that that's of interest.
So it has to range from
0 to the denominator.
And that tells us
that the fraction
has to range from 0 to 1.
So 1 says it's always
going to happen, 0 never.
So if the probability of
an event occurring is p,
what's the probability
of it not occurring?
This follows from
the first bullet.
It's simply going
to be 1 minus p.
This is a trick that we'll
find we'll use a lot.
Because it's often
the case when you
want to compute the probability
of something happening,
it's easier to compute the
probability of it not happening
and subtract it from 1.
And we'll see an example
of that later today.
Now, here's the biggie.
When events are
independent of each other,
the probability of all
of the events occurring
is equal to the product of
the probabilities of each
of the events occurring.
So if the probability of A is
0.5 and the probability of B
is 0.4, the probability
of A and B is what?
0.5 times 0.4.
You guys can figure that out.
I think that's 0.2.
So you'd expect
that, that it should
be much smaller than either of
the first two probabilities.
This is the most
common rule, it's
something we use all the
time in probabilities,
the so-called
multiplicative law.
We have to be careful
about it, however,
in that it only holds if
the events are actually
independent.
Two events are independent
if the outcome of one
has no influence on the
outcome of the other.
So when we roll
the die, we assume
that the first
roll, the outcome,
was independent of the--
or the second roll was
independent of the first roll,
independent of the fourth roll.
When we looked at
the two coins, we
assume that heads and
tails of each coin
was independent
of the other coin.
I didn't, for example,
look at one coin
and make sure that the
other one was different.
The danger here is
that people often
compute probabilities assuming
independence when you don't
actually have independence.
So let's look at an example.
For those of you familiar
with American football,
the New England Patriots
and the Denver Broncos
are two prominent teams.
And let's look at
computing the probability
of whether one of them will
lose on a given Sunday.
So the Patriots have a
winning percentage of 7 of 8--
they've won 7 of
their 8 games so far--
and the Broncos 6 of 8.
The probability of both
winning next Sunday,
assuming that this is
indicative of how good they are,
we can get with the
multiplicative rule.
So it's 7/8 times 6/8, or 42/64.
We could simplify that
fraction, I suppose.
Does that makes sense?
So this is probably a pretty
good estimate of both of them
winning next Sunday.
So the probability of at
least one of them losing
is 1 minus that.
So here's an example
of why we often use
the 1 minus rule,
because we could
compute the probability
of both of them
winning by simply multiplying.
And we subtract that from 1.
However, what about
Sunday, December 18?
What's the probability?
Well, as it happens,
that day the Patriots
are playing the Broncos.
So now suddenly, the
outcomes are not independent.
The probability of
one of them losing
is influenced by the probability
of the other winning.
So you would expect
the probability of one
of them losing is much
closer to 1 than 22/64,
which is about 1/3.
So in this case, it's easy.
But as we'll see, as we
get through the term,
there are lots of
cases where you
have to work pretty hard to
understand whether or not two
events really are independent.
And if you get it wrong, you
get a totally bogus answer.
1/3 versus 1 is a
pretty big difference.
By the way, as it happens,
the probability of the Broncos
losing is about 1.
Let's go look at some code.
And we'll go back to
our dice, because it's
much easier to
simulate dice games
than it is to simulate
football games.
So here it is.
And we're going to talk
a lot about simulations.
So here, rather than
rolling the die,
I've written a program to do it.
We've already seen the
code for rolling a die.
And so to run this simulation,
typically what we're doing here
is I'm giving you the goal--
for example, are we
going to get five 1's--
the number of trials--
each trial, in this case,
will be say of length 5--
so I'm going to
roll the same die
five times say 1,000 different
times, and then just some text
as to what I'm going to print.
Almost all the
simulations we look at
are going to start with lines
that look a lot like that.
We're going to
initialize some variable.
And then we're going to
run some number of trials.
So in this case,
we're going to get
from the length of the goal--
so if the goal is
five 1's, then we're
going to roll the dice five
times; if it's 10 runs,
we'll roll it 10 times.
So this is essentially
one trial, one attempt.
And then we'll check
the result. And if it
has the property we want--
in this case, it's
equal to the goal--
then we're going to
increment the total, which
we initialized up here by 1.
So we'll keep track
with just the counting--
the number of trials that
actually meet the goal.
And then when we're done,
what we're going to do
is divide the number
that met the goal
by the number of trials--
exactly the counting
argument we just looked at.
And then we'll print the result.
Almost every
simulation we look at
is going to have this structure.
There'll be an outer loop,
which is the number of trials.
And then inside-- maybe
it'll have a loop,
or maybe it won't--
will be a single trial.
We'll sum up the results.
And then we'll divide
by the number of trials.
Let's run it.
So a couple of things
are going to go on here.
If you look at the code as
we've looked at it before,
what you're seeing is I'm
computing the estimated
probability by the simulation.
And I'm comparing it to the
actual probability, which we've
already seen how to compute.
So if you look at it, there are
a couple of things to look at.
The estimated
probability is pretty
close to the actual
probability but not the same.
So let's go back
to the PowerPoint.
Here are the results.
And there are at least
two questions raised
by this result.
First of all, how
did I know that this is
what would get printed?
Remember, this is random.
How did I know that the
estimate-- well, there's
nothing random about
the actual probability.
But how did I know that
the estimated probability
would be 0?
And why did it print it twice?
Because I messed
up the PowerPoint.
Any rate, so how do I know
what would get printed?
Well a confession--
random.choice
is not actually random.
In fact, nothing we can do in
a computer is actually random.
You can prove that it's
impossible to build
a computer that actually
generates truly random numbers.
What they do instead
is generate numbers
that called pseudorandom.
How do they do that?
They have an algorithm that
given one number generates
the next number in a sequence.
And they start that
algorithm with a seed.
Now, typically,
they get that seed
by reading the clock
of the computer.
So most computers have
a clock that, say,
keeps track of the number of
microseconds since January 1,
1978.
I don't know if
that's still true.
That's what Unix used to do.
So the notion is, you
start your program,
there's no way of knowing how
many microseconds have elapsed.
And so you're getting a random
number to start the process.
Since you don't know
where it starts,
you don't know what
the second number
is, you don't know what the
third number is, you don't
know what the fourth number is.
And so it's predictably
nondeterministic,
because you don't know what
the seed is going to be.
Now, you can imagine
that this makes
programs really hard to debug.
Every time you run it, something
different could happen.
Now, we'll see often you want
them to be unpredictable.
But for now, we want them to
be predictable, makes it easier
prepare PowerPoint.
So what you have is a command.
You can call random.seed
and give it a value
and say, I don't want you to
just choose some random seed,
I want you to use 0 as the seed.
For the same seed, you
always get the same sequence
of random values.
And so what I've done is I
set the seed to be, I think, 0
in this case, not because
there's anything magic about 0,
it's just sort of habit.
But it made it predictable.
As you write programs
with randomness
in and when you're debugging
it, you will almost surely
want to start by setting
random.seed to a value
so you get the same answer.
But make sure you debug it with
more than one value of this,
so you didn't just get
lucky with your seed.
So that's how I knew
what would get printed.
The next question is,
why did the simulation
give me the wrong answer?
The actual probability
is three 0's and 1286.
But it's estimated
a probability of 0.
Why is it wrong?
Well, let's think about this.
I ran 1,000 trials.
What does it mean to say
the probability is zero?
It means that I tried it 1,000
times and didn't ever get
a sequence of five 1's.
So the numerator of the
division at the bottom was 0.
Hence, the answer is 0.
Is this surprising?
Well, no.
Because if that's the actual
probability of getting five
1's, it's not very shocking
that in 1,000 trials
it never happened.
It's not a surprising
result. And so we
have to be careful when we
run these things to understand
the difference between what's in
this case an actual probability
and what statisticians
call a sample probability.
So what we got with
the sample was 0.
So what's the
obvious thing to do?
If you're doing a
simulation of an event
and the event is
pretty rare, you
want to try it on a very
large number of trials.
So let's go back to our code.
And we'll change it to
instead of 1,000, 1,000,000.
You can see up here, by the
way, where I set the seed.
And now, let's run it.
We did a lot better.
If we look at here our
estimated probability,
it's three 0's 128,
still not quite
the actual probability
but darn close.
And maybe if I had
done 10 million,
it would have been even closer.
So if you're
writing a simulation
to compute the
probability of an event
and the event is
moderately rare,
then you better
run a lot of trials
before you believe your
estimated probability.
In a week or so, we'll
actually look at that more
mathematically and
say, what is a lot,
how do we know what is enough.
What are the morals here?
Moral one, I've just told you--
takes a lot of trials to get a
good estimate of the frequency
of a rare event.
Moral two, we should always,
if we're getting an estimated
probability, know
that, and probably
say that, and not confuse it
with the actual probability.
The third moral here
is, it was kind of
stupid to do a simulation.
Since it was a very
simple closed-form answer
that we could compute
that would really tell us
what the actual
probability is, why even
bother with the simulation?
Well, we're going
to see why now,
because simulations
can be very useful.
Let's look at another problem.
This is the famous
birthday problem.
Some of you have seen it.
What's the probability of at
least two people in a group
having the same birthday?
There's a URL at the bottom.
That's pointing
to a Google form.
I'd like please all of you
who have a computing device
to go to it and fill
out your birthday.
It's anonymous, so we won't know
how old you are, don't worry.
Actually, it's only the date.
It's not the year.
So suppose there were 367
people in the group, roughly
the number of people who
took the 6.0001 600 midterm.
If they are 367 people, what's
the probability of at least two
of them sharing a birthday?
One, by something called
the pigeonhole principle.
You got some number of holes.
And if you have more
pigeons than holes,
two pigeons have
to share a whole.
What about smaller numbers?
Well, if we make a
simplifying assumption
that each birthdate
is equally likely,
then there's actually a nice
closed-form solution for it.
Again, this is a question
where it's easier
to compute the opposite
of what you're trying
to do and subtract it from 1.
And so this fraction is giving
the probability of two people
not sharing a birthday.
The proof that this is right,
it's a little bit elaborate.
But you can trust
me, it's accurate.
But it's a formula, and it's
not that complicated a formula.
So numbers like 366
factorial are big.
So let's approximate a solution.
We'll right a simulation and
see if we get the same answer
that that formula gave us.
So here's the code for that--
two arguments-- the
number of people
in the group and the
number that we asking do
they have the same birthday.
So since I'm assuming for now
that every birthday is equally
likely, the possible
dates range from 1 to 366,
because some years
have a February 29.
I'll keep track of the number
of people born in each date
by starting with none.
And then for p in the
range of number of people,
I'll make a random choice
of the possible dates
and increment that
element of the list by 1.
And then at the end,
we can say, look
at the maximum
number of birthdays
and see if it's greater than
or equal to the number of same.
So that tells us that.
And then we can actually look
at the birthday problem--
number of people, the number
of same, and, as usual,
the number of trials.
So the number of hits is 0 for
t in range number of trials.
If sameDate is true, then
we'll increment the number
of hits by 1 and then as usual
divide by the number of trials.
And we'll try it for 10,
20, 40, and 100 people.
And then just, we'll print
the estimated probability
and the actual
probability computed using
that formula I showed you.
I have not shown you,
but I've imported
a library called
math, because it
is a factorial implementation.
It's way faster than
the recursive one
that we've seen before.
Let's run it.
And we'll see what we get.
So for 10, the estimated
probability is 0.11 now.
So you can see, the estimates
are really pretty good.
Once again, we have this
business that for 100,
we're estimating 1, when the
real answer is point many,
many 9's.
But again, this is
sample probability.
It just means in the number
of trials we did, every 1
for 100 people, there
was a shared birthday.
This is a number that
usually surprises people,
as to why with 100 people
the probability is so high.
But we could work out
the formula and see it.
And as you can
see, the estimates
are pretty good
from my simulation.
Now, we're going to see
why we did a simulation
in the first place.
Suppose we want the probability
of three people sharing
a birthday instead of two.
It's pretty easy to see how
we changed the simulation.
I even made a parameter.
I just changed the
number 2 to number 3.
The math, on the
other hand, is ugly.
Why is the math so much
uglier for 3 than for 2?
Because for 2, the
complementary problem--
the number we're
subtracting from 1--
is simply the question of,
are all birthdays different?
So did two people share a
birthday is 1 minus or all
does everybody have
a different birthday.
On the other hand, for 3 people,
the complementary problem is
a complicated disjunct--
a bunch of ors--
either all birthdays
are distinct,
or two people share a birthday
and the rest are distinct,
or there are two groups of
two people sharing a birthday
and everything is distinct.
So you can see here, there's
a lot of possibilities.
And so it's 1 minus now a
very complicated formula.
And in fact, if you try
and look how to do this,
most people will tell
you don't bother.
Here's kind of a
good approximation.
But the math gets very hairy.
In contrast, changing the
simulation is dead easy.
We can do that.
Whoops.
So if we come over here for
the code, all I have to do
is change this to 2 or 3.
And I'm going to leave
in this code, which
is the wrong code, computing
the actual probability now
for 2 people sharing rather
than 3, because I want
to make it easy for you to see
the difference between what
happens when we look at 3
shared rather than 2 shared.
And I get invalid syntax.
That's not good.
That's what happens when
I type in real time.
Why do I have invalid syntax?
AUDIENCE: Line 56.
JOHN GUTTAG: Pardon.
JOHN GUTTAG: One person, Anna.
AUDIENCE: Line 56,
there's a comma.
JOHN GUTTAG: Oh.
That's not a good line.
So now, we see that if we get,
say, to n equals 100, for 2,
you'll remember, it was 0.99.
But for 3, it's only 0.63.
So we see going from two
sharing to three sharing
gets us a radically different
answer, not surprisingly.
But we also-- and the real
thing I wanted you to see--
is how easy it was to
answer this question
with the simulation.
And that's a primary
reason we use simulations
to get probabilistic
questions rather
than sitting down and
the pencil and paper
and doing fancy
probability calculations,
because it's often way
easier to do a simulation.
We can see that in spades if
we look at the next question.
Let's think about
this assumption
that all birthdays
are equally likely.
Well, as you can
see, this is a chart
of how common birthdates
are in the US, a heat map.
And you'll see, for
example, that February 29
is quite an uncommon birthday.
So we should probably
treat that differently.
Somewhat surprisingly,
you'll see
that July 4 is a very
uncommon birthday as well.
It's easy to understand
why February 29.
The only thing I can
figure out for July 4
is obstetricians don't
like working on holidays.
And so they induce
labor sometime
around the 2nd or
the 3rd, so they
don't have to come to work
on the 4th or the 5th.
Sounds a horrible thought.
But I can't think of any other
explanation for this anomaly.
You'll probably,
if you look at it,
see Christmas day is
not so common either.
So now, the question,
which we can
answer, since you've
all fill out this form,
is how exceptional
are MIT students?
We like to think that you're
different in every respect.
So are your birthdays
distributed differently
than other dates?
Have we got that data?
So now we'll go look at that.
We should have a heat
map for you guys.
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
I removed all the February 31.
Thank you for those submissions.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN GUTTAG: So here it is.
And we can see that,
well, they don't
seem to be banded quite as
much in the summer months,
probably says more about your
parents than it does about you.
But you can see that,
indeed, we do have--
wow, we have a day
where there are
five birthdays, that look like?
Or no?
AUDIENCE: February 12.
JOHN GUTTAG: Wow.
You want to raise your hand
if you're born on February 12?
[LAUGHTER]
So you are exceptional in that
you lie about when you're born.
But if you hadn't lied, I
think we would have still seen
the probabilities would hold.
How many people were
there, do we know?
AUDIENCE: 146 with
112 unique birthdays.
JOHN GUTTAG: 146 people,
So indeed, the
probability does work.
So we know you're
exceptional in a funny way.
Well, you can
imagine how hard it
would be to adjust the
analytic model to account
for a weird distribution
of birthdates.
But again, adjusting the
simulation model is easy.
I could have gone
back to that heat
map I showed you of
birthdays in the US
and gotten a separate
probability for each day,
but I was too lazy.
And instead, what I observed
was that we had a few days,
like February 29, highly
unlikely, and this band
in the middle of people
who were conceived
in the late fall
and early winter.
So what I did is I
duplicated some dates.
So the 58th day of the year,
February 29, occurs only once.
The dates before
that, I said, let's
pretend they occur four times.
What only matters
here is not how often
they occur but the
relative frequency.
And then the dates after
that occur four times
except for the dates in
that band, which is going
to have occur yet more often.
So now-- and don't worry
about the exact details here--
but what I'm doing is simply
adjusting the simulation
to change the probability
of each date getting
chosen by same date.
And then I can run
the simulation model.
And, again, with a very
small change to code,
I've modeled something
that's mathematically
enormously complex.
I have no idea how to
actually do this probability
mathematically.
But the code is, as you can
see, quite straightforward.
So let's go to that here.
So what I'm going to do
is comment this one out
and uncomment this more
complicated set of dates
and see what we get.
And again, it changes
quite dramatically.
You might remember, before
it was around I think
0.6-something for 100,
and now, it's 0.75.
So getting away from the notion
that birthdays are uniformly
distributed to saying
some birthdays are
more common than others,
again, dramatically changes
the answer.
And we can easily look at that.
So that gets us to the big
topic of simulation models.
It's a program that
describes a computation that
provides information about the
possible behaviors of a system.
I say possible
behaviors, because I'm
particularly interested
in stochastic systems.
They're descriptive not
prescriptive in the sense
that they describe
the possible outcomes.
They don't tell you how to
achieve possible outcomes.
This is different
from what we've
looked at earlier in
the course, where we
looked at optimization models.
So an optimization
model is prescriptive.
It tells you how to
achieve an effect,
how to get the most value
out of your knapsack,
how to find the shortest
path from A to B in a graph.
In contrast, a
simulation model says,
if I do this,
here's what happens.
It doesn't tell you how to
make something happened.
So it's very
different, and it's why
we need both, why we
need optimization models
and we need simulation models.
We have to remember that
a simulation model is only
an approximation to reality.
I put in an approximation to
the distribution of birthdates,
but it wasn't quite right.
And as the very famous
statistician George Box said,
"all models are wrong, but
some are actually very useful."
In the next lecture, we'll look
at a useful class of models.
When do we use simulations?
Typically, as we've just
shown, to model systems that
are mathematically intractable,
like the birthday problem
we just looked at.
In other situations, to
extract intermediate results--
something happens along
the way to the answer.
And as I hope you've
seen that simulations
are used because we can play
what if games by successively
refining it.
We started with a
simple simulation
that assumed that we only
asked the question of, do
two people share a birthday.
We showed how we could change
it to ask do three people share
a birthday.
We then saw that
we could change it
to assume a different
distribution of birthdates
in the group.
And so we can start
with something simple.
And we get it ever
more complexed
to answer questions what if.
We're going to start
in the next lecture
by producing a simulation
of a random walk.
And with that, I'll stop.
And see you guys soon.